[Applause]
thank you thank you so much I have to
say this has been one of the most
inspiring heartfelt commencements that
I've ever experienced and I am thrilled
I'm thrilled to be a part of it today
Madam President that has a nice ring to
it thank you so much and thanks
especially for the very personal
descriptions of a few of the members of
this class I think honestly we could be
here for a couple of days hearing each
and every one of your stories and I for
one would welcome that so let me thank
president Raab and the trustees trustee
Schwarz and trustee sunshine and the
couny system the faculty parents family
members distinguished guests but most of
all this amazing brilliant class of 2019
[Applause]
it is an honor for me to follow in the
footsteps of the illustrious speakers
who have addressed previous hunter
commencements Herold and ken and I were
talking about Bela Abzug who gave a
memorable commencement some years ago
now last year it was an alumnus Vin
Diesel and you you might think that we
are an odd pair but I'm actually a big
fan and I can let you in on this
secret we're going to star in a movie
together it's called the fast and the
still really furious
but that's a story for another day
because today we are here to celebrate
you after all you are the inheritors of
a remarkable legacy and a quite radical
idea when 150 years ago in another time
of technological change and demographic
shifts and political turmoil a few wise
New Yorkers joined with mr. hunter to
create this institution because they
realized that educating women could
change everything
[Music]
and and not just the daughters of the
elite but the daughters of immigrants
and factory workers and even former
slaves and the women of Hunter became
the teachers of New York and those
teachers shaped generations of students
and transformed this city and with it
the world and with the admission of men
after World War Two Hunter continued to
grow and develop into the world-class
college it is today so those are the
shoulders you stand on to be a college
graduate is a wonderful thing but to be
a hunter graduate that is something to
shout from the rooftops
so congratulations to each and every one
of you and I'm sure that sitting here
you've had time to reflect about the
setbacks and the struggles along the way
we heard about some of those and the
students stories the graduate stories
that were described some of those
setbacks I'm sure were quite painful but
here you are you are living witnesses to
one of the most important lessons in
life it is not whether you get knocked
down it's whether you get back up and
keep going each of you is here today
because you don't quit right you worked
harder you dreamed bigger and you
reached higher and I am so proud of you
I don't personally know any of you who
are graduating but I have to tell you
I've been up there just beaming like I'm
related to most of you and particularly
to the parents the spouses the children
the family members who've helped make
this day possible thank you you are
living proof
[Applause]
you are living proof that it really does
take a village and to the graduates I
will not say today that now you head off
into the real world because you've been
living and working in the real world all
your lives but today is a turning point
it is a chance to ask as the poet Mary
Oliver does what is it you plan to do
with your one wild and precious life and
it is fitting that this graduation is
here in Madison Square Garden where so
many dramatic events have occurred now
with all due respect it has been a long
time since an important basketball game
was played here
but there's always next year
but this garden has seen its share of
history from all kinds of championships
to concerts to political conventions we
have seen the best of America here like
the concert for New York and our brave
first responders just weeks after 9/11
but as I was thinking about coming here
because this too is a historic event
this graduation I thought about an event
that happened here 80 years ago on
February 20th 1939 when instead of the
inspirational stories we heard this
arena was filled with 20,000 chanting
stomping Americans rallying in support
of Nazi Germany cheering calls for a
quote socially just white Gentile ruled
United States attacks on Jews attacks on
the press that's right 20,000 Nazis and
Nazi sympathizers right here in the
heart of the most diverse city in the
world at that time it was a warning that
America was not immune from the hate
running rampant across Europe and it was
a call to arms to those who believed
that the United States was the last best
hope for freedom and democracy today I
wish that felt like ancient history
after all it would have made those Nazis
so furious to see all of us here and to
look out at your faces
in the same Hall where fascists once
planted their flag this incredible
diverse brilliant class of 2019 stands
tall and proud and that my friends is
the real story of America now we have
never been perfect but we have never
stopped striving for a more perfect
union and yet all these years later our
democracy feels far from secure last
September I had the honor of receiving a
Human Rights Award from the American Bar
Association at Roosevelt House on the
hunt
soldier in World War 2 he'd helped to
liberate concentration camps afterward
he served as a prosecutor at the
Nuremberg war crimes trials and then he
worked to create the International Court
of Justice at 99 years of age he was
here at Hunter to issue a warning when
he listens to voices in our government
who reject the rule of law he hears
echoes of the fascists he worked so hard
to defeat and then bring to justice and
I knew what he meant over the past two
years
we've seen people wearing Nazi symbols
once again marching in American cities
carrying torches and chanting hate in
Charlottesville Virginia they killed a
brave young woman named Heather Haier
we've seen a surge in hate crimes across
America shootings an arson at synagogues
mosques and churches Americans targeted
because of their race religion or sexual
orientation
and instead of standing up against
bigotry and white supremacy this
administration has too often worked to
tear down hard-won civil rights they've
banned Muslims from entering the country
ripped away protections for transgender
Americans waged war on voting rights for
people of color poor people and young
people and our government is tearing
children from the arms of their parents
at the border and locking them in cages
recently we learned about a sixth child
to die in federal custody a ten year old
girl from El Salvador it took eight
months
truth to come out about what happened to
her how many more children are suffering
right now how many more have gone
missing or died and how many will never
see their parents again now I'm not
talking about disputes over politics or
policy we can and we should have
vigorous disagreements in our country
but this is something different there
may not be tanks in our streets but make
no mistake we are witnessing an assault
on the rule of law and the foundations
of our democracy just today before this
graduation the ceremony started we heard
from the special counsel Robert Muller
who said there were multiple systemic
efforts to interfere in our election and
that allegation deserves the attention
of every American but what we've seen
from the administration is the complete
refusal to condemn a foreign power who
attacked our democracy or to take even
the most basic steps to protect our
voting systems for the future despite
the fact that all of the professionals
who study this say more attacks are
coming and it's so clear that there is a
real challenge to get to the root of
that problem in fact it seems clear it
seems absolutely clear that we've got to
deal with what has been investigated and
reported now when I think about the
future I think about what do we do when
people in positions of authority are not
held accountable when they defy request
from the Congress when they spread
misinformation online now why do I bring
this up at this joyous occasion
your graduation because the future of
this democracy truly does depend on you
and I know that's asking a lot and it
can be tempting to read the news and
throw your hands up and conclude nothing
matters nothing will change so why even
bother but it does really really matter
and this is no time for apathy instead
it should be a time for action
because
[Applause]
the question for each of us to answer
especially you graduates is will the
symbol of this troubled age be the
cynics shrug or will it be the raised
hand of the volunteer the activists
rolled up sleeves the linked arms and
marching feet of people who demand
justice and democracy the answer is up
to all of us and yes it is up to you and
the spirit you've shown fills me with
such hope the big-hearted hard-working
expectations defying spirit that earned
you these diplomas is exactly what this
country needs right now and to guide you
as you begin to chart your own future
here are just a few lessons I've learned
in the trenches over the years
first citizenship is not a spectator
sport you've got to get in the game and
in a time when we are go set by lies and
propaganda it is more important than
ever to seek out credible sources of
information and to use the critical
thinking skills you learned at Hunter to
decide what is important and what is
true and it is even more critical to
hold leaders accountable not only the
wrongdoers but the others who fail to
act most of them know what needs to be
done they just lack the political will
to do it now in the Congress the House
of Representatives has already passed
sweeping legislation to strengthen
voting rights and crackdown on
corruption but the Senate won't act
unless it feels real pressure from the
public or unless enough of the
obstructionist in the Senate are retired
by the voters in the next election
[Applause]
and then we can act on what nonpartisan
experts tell us we need to do to protect
future elections from foreign
interference we need hand marked paper
ballots mandatory cybersecurity audits
better training for state and local
officials but it will not happen unless
voters send the message they actually
care and similarly the big social media
platforms know their systems are being
manipulated by foreign and domestic
actors too so division promote extremism
and spread misinformation but they won't
get serious about cleaning up their
platforms
unless consumers demanded and we saw why
it's so important just last week when
Facebook refused to take down a fake
video of Nancy Pelosi it wasn't even a
close call the video is sexist trash and
YouTube took it down but Facebook kept
it up so let's send a message to
Facebook that those who are in
Facebook's communities would really like
Facebook to pay attention to false and
doctored videos before we are flooded
with them over the next month
you know the motto of the Washington
Post as democracy dies and darkness but
you could also say democracy suffocates
in silence and the only way to breathe
new life into this great Republic of
ours is to make such a racket that no
one can ignore us that's our job as
citizens and as hunter graduates you
have the tools and skills you need to be
forceful voices on behalf of truth
integrity and democracy and here's the
second lesson progress is not a straight
line so don't lose heart we all falter
as individuals as parts of movements for
change I've stumbled many times and you
know there were days after the 2016
election when all I wanted to do was
scream into a pillow or disappear into
the woods not just because of the
personal disappointment I felt but
because of what it meant for the country
and and for the many millions of people
whose lives would now be affected
adversely but again the important the
important thing is don't quit turn your
failures into fuel turn your pain into
purpose and if you want inspiration look
at your classmates look at the profiles
of your fellow graduates that we have
just seen look at the students from
parkland Florida who have campaigned for
common-sense gun-safety reform
[Applause]
they have cut through all the tired old
talking points of the gun lobby and
their lackeys in Congress they channeled
their trauma and their loss into an
activist inference infrastructure that
will continue driving progress long
after the cable news cameras have moved
on groups like mom moms demand action
and Everytown for gun safety are
organizing fundraising registering
voters supporting candidates and
legislation and the enthusiasm and
energy of the Parkland students and so
many other young people has turbocharged
these efforts and that kind of activism
is not always glamorous but it is how
you make progress step by step year by
year door by door because you need to
change both hearts and laws you have to
stir up public opinion put pressure on
political leaders shift policies and
priorities and win elections so yes we
have a way to go but 2018 was a pretty
good start and for the first time the
gun lobby was outspent in elections and
states passed more than three times as
many gun safety reforms as they did the
prior year and people who stood for
common-sense gun safety beat incumbents
who boasted about their ratings from the
NRA and one of the unlikely winners was
my friend Lucy Macbeth whose son Jordan
Davis was murdered in Jacksonville
Florida Lucy and a group of other
grieving moms formed an organization
known as the mothers of the movement
they spoke in churches and community
centers all over the country and today
Lucy Macbeth is a United States
congresswoman
so as scripture tells us let us not grow
weary in doing good for in due season we
shall reap if we do not lose heart
so try fail try again lean on each other
hold on to your values and never never
give up and third and finally progress
does not come just from grand
aspirations or speeches it comes from
the small gestures and the habits of our
hearts you have honoured me today with
an award named for one of my heroes
Eleanor Roosevelt and as you already
heard one of the wisest things Eleanor
ever said is that human rights start not
in the gilded halls of palaces or
courthouses but in small places close to
home neighborhoods schools offices
factories farms in the hearts and daily
interactions of people everywhere that
is where all great social movements
start it's where democracy starts and is
sustained you know one of the most
perceptive observers of our early
democracy was the French writer Alexis
de Tocqueville he wrote about America in
the 1918 30s and he used a phrase that I
particularly love he used the phrase
habits of the heart just to describe
what he found here a nation of rugged
individualist who still deeply believed
in community you know like Benjamin
Franklin who formed the first volunteer
fire department because he figured out
if your neighbor's house is on fire it's
your problem two Americans join clubs
and civic organizations and
congregations and political parties and
that volunteer spirit made America's
great democratic experiment possible and
what's the 2019 version of that well
it's going to Puerto Rico to help
rebuild after the hurricane
as some of you have done it's
volunteering at the local women's
shelter or helping refugees who just
moved in settle down the block as some
of you have done that too it's doing
what generations of hunter graduates
have done teaching in schools where
students are desperate for mentors who
can give them a fighting chance to
succeed nursing in hospitals and other
settings where people literally will
live or die because of your care
practicing social work in some of the
darkest most desolate places that need
your light and skill this country was
built by people who had each other's
backs and the future depends on you and
us summoning that same spirit even after
everything that's happened and all the
challenges we face I have great faith in
this country and in our and your future
there was a dark dark moment that I
mentioned earlier that happened 80 years
ago but 20 plus years ago right here I
had a much happier memory it was at that
time in 1992 that I was here at the
Democratic convention and my husband was
nominated for president it was certainly
a turning point in my life because
before that summer night here in New
York I was a lawyer in Arkansas I was an
advocate for children and families and
improving education I was a mother to a
wonderful twelve-year-old and then
afterward I was a public figure with the
opportunity to work for change on a
global scale but I also had the
challenges of living working and raising
a daughter in the very bright spotlight
I never could have imagined all those
years ago where my life would take me
that I would one day run for office
myself serve our country as Secretary of
State
representing America across the world
that I would become the first woman
nominated by a major party if you had
told me that
[Applause]
if you had told me that back in 1992 I
would not have believed you but if you
had come to see me in Madison Square
Garden that night and said right now
here in New York and across America
there are children being born they will
grow up in a time of turmoil terrorist
attacks a Great Recession staggering
inequality but they will be the most
diverse open generous generation in the
history of this nation and they will
save our democracy and build a better
future for our country if you had told
me that I would have smiled and said yes
because that's America that is the
promise of America that is the American
dream
your story's class of 2019 are the story
of America in the 21st century many of
you are the first in your family to go
and graduate from college you are
immigrants and the children of
immigrants you are workers and parents
and activists and organizers you are
strivers and seekers you are lifting up
yourself and your families and your
communities and your success is the
testament to the persistence and power
of the American Dream yes the motto of
Hunter is the care of the future is mine
so take that as your charge the future
is yours to claim but also to care for
do us and yourselves proud I believe in
you and I believe in the future that
awaits you and that you will help to
shape hunter class of 2019
congratulations and good luck
[Applause]